عملاقه تقنيه ميته في خطوه يراها البعض
متوقع لم تعد منصات العالميه فيسبوك او
انستجرام مجانيه بشكل كامل بعد اليوم
فالعلامه الزرقاء او رمز التحقق باسمها
التقني اصبحت من الان فصاعدا بمقابل مادي
بدايه استراليا نيوزيلندا الاسبوع المقبل
العلامه التي حملت قيمه مضافه واصبحت بابا
يطرقه المشاهير ليوثقوا حساباتهم تواجه
اليوم تهديدا ان تفقد قيمتها ونجوميتها
خصوصا مع رفض عدد لا باس به ان يدفعوا
مقابلها لكن الخساره قد تكون متبادله بين
ميثا والمشاهير وهذا الربح الذي ترجوه متى
قد ينعكس سلبا على قيمه العلامه الزرقاء
معنويا وربما يكون الاكثر ربحا هم الناس
العاديون فالذي يستطيع الدفع المال سيكون
بحساب جانب صوره العلم الزرقاء
[موسيقى]
علامه زرقاء باشتراك مدفوع ما الاسباب
التي دفعت مثل لذلك اولا بطبيعه الحال
يعني متل ماسكروا بالارقام بالتقرير
السابق انخفضت اذا بدك مداخيل شركه
ميتايلنا عم نحكي فيسبوك وانستجرام وغيرها
باكثر من 8% يعني عم نحكي عشره مليار
دولار لعده اسباب اول سبب اللي هو موضوع
الاعلانات يلي من وراء اللي عم تعمله اذا
بدك ابل بموضوع الخصوصيه ما بقى عم يقدر
ياخدوا كتير معلومات المستخدمين وما عم
بيقدروا يساهم باعلانات فانخفضت مداخلهم
للاعلانات وشفنا اولادي شركه ميتا مثل غير
الشركات والذي ابتدت تطرد عدد كتير كبير
من الموظفين كميه تخفف التكاليف تبعهولها
فهلا عم نجرب الف على مصدر دخل تاني
هل صارت العلامه الزرقاء تجاره مربحه
لعمالقه تكنولوجيا لا قيمه مضافه لصاحب
الحساب
لا هلا هنا بطبيعه الحال اذا بدك شيء مربح
على شركه ميتى او تويتر من الشركات بس
كمان هن شو عم يجي يقدمون خدمات اضافيه
راح يوصل لعدد اكبر من العالم اذا حدا عم
يعمل راح يبين حسابي بشكل افضل راح يكون
في عندك كونتاك مع السبورت تبع شركه ميتا
او تويتر بشكل افضل فهو الخدمات كلهم راح
يكونوا موجودين بس للحسابات الموسطه طيب
اللي ما فهمته
رئيس ميتا يقول ان هذه الخطوه في الدفع
مقابل العلامه الزرقاء سيساهم في الامان
والمصداقيه على تطبيقات منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي لكن منصات اخرى تويتر شهدت شان
نوفمبر الماضي وقف الدفع بسبب نجاح شخص من
اشخاص في انتحال شخصيات كبرى وانتحال صفه
اشخاص مشهورين وقاموا بالاشتراك مقابل
الحصول على العلامه الزرقاء يعني هل هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ما حصل بطبيعه الحال في
مخاوف كرمال هيك تعلم
بس العالم تدفى بدها تاخذ حساب باسم اي
شركه او اي مؤسسه بلا ما تكون مقدمه كل
الاثبات في البراهين لهلا عملوا بميتا انه
ما فيها اي حدا يوسخ
باكد انه صاحب هذا الحساب او هو باكد
ملكيته
[موسيقى]